البدايه او البذره الاولى للتنظيم الاخوان
المسلمين بالذات كان عام 1937 وكان في
اييي منطقتين مكه المكرمه والمدينه
المنوره الا ان تنظيم اخوان الحجاز لم ااه
يعني يسجل بشكل رسمي او يرتبط بشكل رسمي
الا في بدايه الثمانينات الميلاديه لكن
هذا لا يعني انه لم يكن هناك عمل حزبي
تنظيمي في المنطقه
فتقسيمات الاخوان همم في المملكه كما
رصدتها انا اولا اخوان الحجاز وتشمل منطقه
مكه المكرمه المدينه المنوره مدينه جده
الطائف ينبع همم تبوك وعسير واجازان
والباحه وهمم بعض منتسبي لتنظيم في
المنطقه الشرقيه يتبعون لاخوان الحجاز او
تنظيم الحجاز حتى في الشرقيه نعم جزء منهم
همم
علاقات شخصيه
ده قد يكون من ذهب بحكم الدراسه في
الجامعات والمنطقه الشرقيه تفرق في
الارتباط هم يرتبطون الكل يرتبط
بالاعام يعني لكن لكل تنظيم مراقب مسؤول
عنه وله مجلس شورى مستقل همم يتعاونوه
فيما بينهم لكن لهم مرجعيه خارج المملكه
همم التنظيم الثاني هو الاخوان الزبير
وهمم من العراق الذين استعدوا الجنسيه
وهؤلاء ارتباطهم
همم بتنظيم اخوان الكويت ارتباطهم بالهمي
التنظيمي ال- همم القسم الثالث همم لهم
اخوان الرياض وهمم وهؤلاء طبعا انشقوا الى
قسمين همم
تنظيم اخوان الرياض
بمجموعه وشك في تنظيم مستقل صغير ركز فيه
على مناشف معينه همم كل همم يعني نشاط
الجوال في الجامعات وكذا وباقي التنظيم
الرئيسي همم دكتور همم عفوا الاسماء يعني
ما تذكر اسم ما ذكرت رموز اييي لانه ليس
من المهم ان نرصد الفكر والحركه يعني همم
انشقت عن المجموعه فاصبح تنظيم الرياض
تنظيم يعني
التنظيم الخامس اللي هو اخوان الشرقيه
وهؤلاء يعني يعني مستقلون في
تنظيم مستقل ااه ومرتبطون ايضا تنظيميا
هرميا باخوان الكويت كان او نشاط الاخوان
التنظيم العام بهذه التنظيمات الخمسه همم
ما بين عام 1967 الى عام 1991 كانت
قواعدهم كبيره ومكتسحه